all right he is the former u.s. national
coordinator for security is the
structure protection and cause of
terrorism his latest book as warnings
finding casandra's to stop catastrophes
Richard Clarke is back with us great to
see you okay so you are the man who is
famous for the phrase my hair was on
fire well it was and see the all go it's
done exactly when you were going around
right before 9/11 saying bin Laden's
going to attack if you are right on that
but there was something else your hair
was on fire about which was cyberspace
alright the attacks that could come from
there you have been proved to be
prescient once again so I'm going to
start with the question that's most on
my mind which is the election of 2018
the election of 2020 are you confident
they will be they'll be back the
Russians the Russians will be back are
you confident those elections will be on
the up-and-up because I'm not even sure
about that Georgia election we just had
because he was ahead in the polls once
again the head in the polls and then I
guess something happened look after what
happened in the last election the US
government should have instituted a very
comprehensive program to make sure the
Russians could never get involved in our
democracy again and we've done nothing
nothing at all and as you know as Jim
Comey said they will be back they'll be
back in 18 it's harder at the
Congressional level but they'll do it
and they'll certainly be back trying to
re-elect me but it seems like each time
we hear about the Russia story it gets a
little worse at first it was just well
they were just hacking Hillary Clinton's
email that would the thing then it was
say you know well they were trying to
get into the voting machines but and
then it was well they did get into the
voting machine the thing that they did
that matters the most gets the least
attention which is they had thousands
tens of thousands of fake Facebook and
Twitter accounts and they were micro
targeting individual voters in
individual swing districts Wow
shaping their opinion psychological
warfare on a grand scale they conducted
the largest psychological warfare
campaign in history and they want
and and somehow the president's going to
meet with Putin next week Farage
advisers will not even say that he's
going to bring this up no he won't
yeah he doesn't he was the beneficiary
of course that's why he's not
investigating it right that's why he's
not doing all the things we need to do
to make sure it can't happen again
that's crazy that's crazy that like so
many of his voters think you know what
when you're when you're dealing with
crooked Hillary in the deep state what's
the big problem with having Putin help
you out that's this this is the 20
mental change isn't it in how Americans
think it is and this is the 21st century
equivalent of having the Russians land
Marines on the New Jersey Shore right
you know they invaded our country they
invaded our political system and they
won and he doesn't care because he won
so there was a ransomware attack this
week for 10 grand somewhere attack what
is the protected so it pretended to be
ransomware send us 300 dollars in
Bitcoin and we give you your computer
back actually what I was doing was
erasing all the files permanently on all
of those computers so they weren't
looking for money no no no what why did
they do it now they did it to think it
was Russia they were attacking us a
Russia it was Russia they were attacking
Ukraine and it slipped and got out of
Ukraine he was supposed to just attack
Ukraine and wipe out all the files now
look we've done this too we attacked the
Iranian nuclear facility and we're
supposed to just be the Iranian nuclear
facility and our our little worm got out
and slipped around around the world to
Hawks net yeah well you the problem but
these little worms is you know once you
create them they have a mind of their
own
same true of my worm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was in the bleeding discussion but
okay but here's my question of a real
expert like I'm in terrorist plots what
we know is that the ones that succeed
are the ones we hear about but there are
many other ones that were stopped all
the time is that true of these kind of
hacking attacks are we just hearing
about the ones that succeed and many
others are stopped No or do they all
succeed no we're just hearing about 1/10
of those who succeed most of the ones
that succeed the companies that are
attacked done even though it's happened
so what you're saying is they all
succeed they don't all succeed but they
have a high rate of success they have a
very high rate of success I'm going to
don't know how to stuff and we don't
know how to stop and then the people who
do it never get punished [ __ ] because
they're all in Russia well when I when
my friends knew that you were coming on
my married friends they wanted to ask
this question especially the men is my
internet history safe no with all this
talk of blackmail go around no people
Google knows at all
Google notes at all so you better be
friends with Google now okay so uh
Cassandra that's your book yeah for
those who are forgetful of their Greek
mythology who was gisado Cassandra was a
woman who was blessed by the gods to see
the future accurately as you have and
cursed by the gods that no one would
ever pay attention right because people
really don't pay attending has never
happened before so what should we be
thinking about now although it dooms in
the book in the book we looked at seven
people who were right in the past okay
and seven people who are saying [ __ ] now
all right
and the one that's the most scary is sea
level rise sea level so the Cassandra's
are outliers they're experts but all the
other experts disagree so why should you
pay attention to them that's the
question right well if you look at their
data if you take them seriously enough
to hear them out and test their data
they usually are right and now we've got
this guy Jim Hanson who was the first
one to say climate change is out asset
right great guy Jim
Hanson is now saying the UN model that
says a meter of sea level rise by 2100
is off it will actually be six to nine
meters he says by 2100 now if he's if
he's even off by a factor at 50% say
goodbye to Florida oh yeah and
Bangladesh and a lot of other things you
know like Florida but they all have
summer homes in Bangladesh
[Applause]